well I think from I think for fairly
early on although I didn't realize it
myself
I was really preoccupied with race
relations and with slavery and I didn't
consciously pursue that as subject
matter but I was very interested in
inequality and injustice we just built
into that system and power relationships
so I think that those you know those old
stories which in many ways are dashing
and romantic they're also full of
horrific violence and and just plain
cruelty
I think that had a big influence on my
writing which was it's pretty sometimes
pretty gothic I guess although I never
see I never can't see it as much as
other people seem to it's certainly
writing this preoccupied with
relationships of power well some years
ago many years ago I wrote a book called
the Great Divorce and it has three
stories in it and one of the stories is
a story about a woman who murders her
husband oh and it takes place in
Antebellum times on a plantation and she
turns into a weapon very very mysterious
and magical and horrific and in that
story I wrote a little bit about her one
of her slaves and some things that
happened to the slaves and I described
the plantation life a bit i-s maybe 20
years later in reading about slavery I
thought you know perhaps I romanticized
that a bit now one of my great missions
as a writer has been to D romanticize
the world because I think that Americans
still receive a romantic education and
that it ill fits them for life so when I
in looking back over my own writing
thought I had romanticized something as
important as this is important as
slavery I was very upset so I said about
to repair that and do romanticize it and
that was really
property came about well it's
historically accurate if there was
slaves who were really pretty bad
condition and then there were women who
were maybe a cut above and then there
were free white men who have always been
at the top of every every every scheme
there is to to oppress but I was not
trying to suggest as as has been
suggested in reviews and commentary that
this rather brutal woman men on go day
is in just as bad condition as her slave
because she isn't in fact she can get a
divorce she can't own property her slave
is her property and can own nothing so I
think there is certainly a big
difference between those two characters
but I've had many people talk about how
they felt sympathetic from and all
because she was herself property well
just some extent that's true and I'm
glad to hear that they're able to feel
that it's very hard to get Americans to
feel sympathy for each other really uh
in fiction but I was not consciously
trying to suggest that she was in as bad
as straight as the slave who she chases
clear across the country in order to get
her back again um she's very jealous of
the slave because the slave has children
by her husband and she has no children
basically in setting up a novel like
that where we have these degrees of
power and everybody owned something and
some of the some people own people um
more or less I really just want it to be
so complicated that you pull your hair
and think where is the end of property
and so that's why I think there is a
spare allel between degrees of ownership
the woman who owns the slave the slavery
was nothing the husband who wants a wife
and so forth